okay well you clearly don't care so why
don't you just leave I would like to
stay this pertains to me I would like
you to leave why don't you go outside
and take a shot of insulin and have a
nap okay why do you always assume I have
diabetes you have a glass of apple juice
and tell me that you don't have diabetes
okay all right see just the noise you
made when you stood up I
could
hey if Sabre truly cared about a
long-term well-being they would set up
hand desanitizing stations hold up
what's a hand desanitizing station bowl
of dirt okay you
understand this is oh my
God that's a good impro okay you
understand the more we expose ourselves
to germs the
[Laughter]
stronger we have three sex or or heavy
petting closets one masturbation closet
does anyone have a problem with that yes
gay closet five that was five closet
that's that that wasn't the problem
three heavy pading closets one
masturbation closet and one gay closet
absolutely problem everybody happy with
a glory hole what well I heard about it
somewhere holy fifth closet will have a
glory
hole I throw a corpse dressed like me
off of the roof it hits the ground yep
the head pops off this leads to me
saying the line I lost my head when I
fell in love with you that's a guarantee
Paula Poundstone what about her how
would that
work I I throw po p the
roof all right we got to get
that is that the buzzer from taboo shut
up maggot you don't want to go ring the
bell ring it ring
it ah that doesn't count ring it with
your hand I can't do
that ring the bell you want to spend the
rest of your life changing your
husband's colostomy bags huh do you ring
it
what
ring
it what was that mosquito
God oh
man okay uh orientation over
that this is not a joke this is not a
carnival
car
car what it is I want you all to be bons
okay Bavon is a girl's
name you need to shut the
up here's your
headline Scranton Paper Company Dunder
Mifflin apologizes to valued client some
companies still know how business is
done it's more like the whole
article I don't mean to be crash but get
prepared to get wet
because God wow there was no double
meaning in
that there wasn't you couldn't even get
through it it's the most horrible thing
I'm so sorry when it came out for soccer
practice I I pinched
him where did you pinch
him
Phyllis yogurt
container Phyllis yogurt
container this here is a Ron test kit
okay I'll be putting them everywhere and
please don't throw these
out this is a raon test
kit please don't throw these
out see them all over the
[Laughter]
[Music]
office that's okay
random
this here
Plantation is running low on green BS um
we ain't got no money to pay the people
who sell us the sides and dirt M I can't
do
thisa
[Laughter]
basically okay wait there it is uh it is
rumored that they will declare I can't I
can't see
um you don't know your
Lance I lost bankruptcy what are you
talking about Kevin will be eaten Pam
will be taken slave Andy will be made a
warlord's Jester and Meredith will do
just fine what can I
do your skull will
be I'll try
again what can I do your skull will be
made of soup ball
what can I do your skull will be made of
soup bowl
cool going on what can I
do your I'm sorry I'm sorry what can I
do your skull will be a soup bowl
cool eat spicy foods what is the
opposite of that make spicy foods come
out out of her okay Noe
no eat spicy foods okay okay what is the
opposite of that take spicy foods come
out of her nope okay nope nope we're not
doing that
Pam okay so what is it eat spicy foods
and the opposite of that oh make spicy
food well hello
everybody
hello
everybody oh
man Phyllis did I or did I not say fruit
you did say fruit and what is that cake
and what did I say
fruit sorry
is is this is this funny to you
Phyllis she's nervous yeah well she
should be nervous because I'm about to
kick her
ass I'm going to walk in
again Phyllis we gave you one hell of a
wedding shower it was a golden shower
Phyllis we all gave you a
gold we all came in this room for your
wedding and gave you you
a we all came in here and gave you a
golden shower well where's my golden
sh hi Holly yeah hi I'm Paul I'm
Toby oh man Paul that's fantastic okay
go hi
Paul
Dwight
[Laughter]
question that was funny that was funny
that was like faulty TOS
[Laughter]
Dwight I can sit on your lap now you can
sit on my lap all you want because I am
a male Santa and that is something that
Phyllis cannot do oh my God okay this is
really
comfortable okay tell me what you want
little
boy I don't know I didn't know you were
going to ask me that what did you think
was going to happen I didn't know no
one's ever let me sit on their lap
before hurry up just say some
toys can can you give me some choices oh
my God Kevin please
sorry copper squat here we
go
sorry squat I'm glad what would you like
for Christmas little
Kevin I don't
know I didn't know you were going to ask
me that well what did you think was
going to happen
here
sorry all right here
help